ich versuche ihm gleich mal die
wochenend laune donald trump wird im
nächsten jahr wieder zum präsidenten
gewählt so meine prognose
das bedeutet fünf muss von dieser
endlosen horror show fürchte ich fürchte
ich weil es den tram fans in den usa
einfach völlig gruppe ist wie dreist der
orange man hier sein amt missbraucht
jetzt gibt es öffentliche impeachment
anhörung in washington alles liegt auf
dem tisch
trump persönlich hat wie wir seit dieser
woche wissen in zwei telefonaten von der
ukraine ermittlungen gegen seinen
rivalen joe biden verlangt den zweiten
anruf hatte aber wohl selber nicht so
richtig mitgekriegt hier
ich glaube vorstufe zur demenz
ich stelle von hier so viel du
ja
ich zähle von ihr so viel offen es am
anderen ende gar keiner dran
und trotzdem gibt es offenbar viele
amerikaner die sich nochmal fünf jahre
ihre sind wünschen
vor allem die evangelikalen diese immer
gehört diese hardcore christen die
liebenden mann egal was er macht solange
er für waffen und gegen abtreibung ist
spielt donald trump im team das letzte
war das einzig vernünftige was da gesagt
wurde
die fragen für diese verstrahlten leute
sind trump und gott quasi ein und
dieselbe person ja nicht zu
unterscheiden identisch wobei ich
zugeben muss manchmal bin ich ja auch
fan wirklich neulich hat er zum beispiel
ganz stolz vom tod des führers badie
berichtet und dann redet er den halt
eben nicht wie ein präsident sondern wie
ein total aufgeregt achtjähriger der zum
ersten mal erfährt wie amerikanische
elitesoldaten so arbeit
ja ja die haben nicht mal klopf klopf
gemacht sondern sprengen und war gar
nicht so süß und wie jedes andere
verhaltensauffällige kind weiß trump
wenn du richtig scheiße baust ganz
schnell ablenken
genau deswegen hat er ja vorgestern
pünktlich zu den im pitch mit anhörung
den türkischen präsidenten erdogan in
washington begrüßt ja wunderbares paar
wunderbares paar
ja wir erinnern uns eher dorns truppen
beginnen in nordsyrien schwere
kriegsverbrechen als führer der
sogenannten freien welt müsste man ihm
dafür mindestens die leviten lesen die
meinung geigen
stattdessen sagt schramm wörtlich ich
bin ein riesen fan von erdogan zitat
ende
und die kurden die den usa neulich noch
im kampf gegen den hass geholfen haben
sind in seiner welt plötzlich die bösen
die hater ist wir wissen alle hassen
isis aber die pkk die ein teil der
kurden ist ist wahrscheinlich eine
größere terroristische bedrohung als
dieses es ist also sehr kompliziert
nicht zu kompliziert wenn man schlau ist
ja genau
wenn man schlau ist wenn man schlau ist
lädt man einen diktator wie er denn
überhaupt nicht ein nach so einer
invasion
wenn man schlau wäre immer noch nie auf
die idee freiwillig türkische propaganda
zu verbreiten oder zu verraten worum es
den usa in syrien wirklich geht
wir haben mit den kurden gesprochen und
sie scheint sehr zufrieden zu sein
wir haben dass das will ist sicher wir
haben truppen nur für das öl gegossen
gott sei dank dem öl geht es gut meine
damen und herren dem übrigens gut vor
allem gehört das öl den syrern ja aber
das ganze konzept anderen gehört was
haben die usa ja nie richtig verstanden
wegen erdogan erleben der as&s hat ein
comeback im nahen osten
der typ erdogan bestellt als
nato-mitglied ein russisches
raketensystem und wird trotzdem
regelrecht folge schleimt vom
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
da war er fast schon romantik im spiel
rosamunde pilcher präsentiert eine
unmögliche liebe zwischen zwei alten
despoten im goldenen herbst ihrer
vertrockneten libido donald gefangen in
einer dreiecksbeziehung mit einer
slowenen und einem weißen hasen hat
inzwischen ernsthafte probleme seinen
säbel hoch zu kriegen und dann
schmachtet ihn ein heißblütiger aus
marne mit einem liebeslied im fernsehen
an
[Musik]
fiebern sie mit wenn zwei notorische
kotzbrocken völlig neue gefühle
entdecken
das ist viel mehr als okay das ist
rosamunde pilchers liebe auf richards
kino im zdf prädikat volle romantisch
außer für kunden
[Musik]
man stellt fest herr erdogan hat
insgesamt gerade richtig oberwasser
diese woche hat er noch mal in richtung
eu gedroht uns noch mehr noch viel mehr
gefangene erst kämpfer zu schicken
zitat erdo diese türen können sich
öffnen dann könnt ihr sehen wie er
zurecht kommt ja das kommt davon wenn
man ein problem wie das mit den
deutschen gs leuten jahrelang ignoriert
wie wir das gemacht haben
wenn weil wer weiß wie viele schon auf
eigene faust nach hause gegangen sind
inzwischen das weiß ja keiner
gestern wurde eine siebenköpfige familie
nach berlin abgeschoben über die wir
nichts wissen nichts da sind kinder
dabei und den erwachsenen irgendwas
gerichtsfest nachzuweisen das ist halt
schwer
viele männer beispielsweise sagen heute
sie waren nur krankenwagenfahrer oder
maurer oder elektroinstallateure beim
sogenannten islamischen staates ja viele
haben bei mir essen auch als
gleichstellungsbeauftragte gabe oder
blockflötenunterricht gegeben
ja
schwer nachzuweisen yogakurse zumba
kurse
[Musik]
zum beispiel zum beispiel ein echtes
problem den verbindung zum esc oder gar
verbrechen nachzuweisen eine große
herausforderung wirklich für unsere
sicherheitsbehörden wir schalten wir
live zum bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
nach köln dort leitet holger stockhaus
die neue abteilung für überraschenden
extremisten besuch der stockhaus was
kommt da auf uns zu
also erstmal herr werke ist das timing
natürlich eine katastrophe als kölner
betrachte ich es als feindlichen akt der
türkei uns diese leute zu schicken
ausgerechnet in der woche des elften
elften in der jecken zeit kannst du hier
so einfach untertauchen mini er werke
wir hätten unsere deutschen längst
selber abholen sollen da in dem noch
syrien die kurden haben uns angefleht
aber wir haben uns herr tot gestellt
ich meine das sind ja unsere
staatsbürger teilweise aus dem rheinland
so was höre ich sofort dass die gehalte
gewaltigste java ist sollte das outfit
machen sondern wir die hat machen
sie hat im keller entschuldigung bei
diesen reflex
so jetzt haben wir den salat
wir hätten da selber hinfliegen und
ermitteln müssen was die da drüben genau
verbrochen haben
jetzt können wir keinen von den vögeln
einsperren die laufen erst mal frei rum
ag
ich hätte ich fast erschossen
herberg meine behörde ist am limit um
einen gefährder komplett zu überwachen
brauchst du 25 bis 30 beamte wie soll
das gehen
seit halle sollen wir jetzt plötzlich
auch noch nazis beobachtet richtig ihr
verfassungsschutz hat ja gerade erst ein
mitarbeiter suspendiert wegen verdacht
auf rechtsextremismus wir wissen halt
noch viel zu wenig über diese rechte da
sind ja völlig neue subkulturen
entstanden hier verfassungsschützer aus
thüringen
wir haben es mit einer
erlebnisorientierten
rechtsextremistischen szene zu tun
es gibt rechtsextremistische veganer es
geht darum den wehrhaften volkskörper zu
verstetigen also nicht dass sie mich
falsch verstehen nicht alle veganes und
rechtsextrem brandgefährlich
rechtsextrem und veganer tödliche
mischung
das sind schlecht gelaunt und nazis mit
blähungen und und wie viel haben wir von
denen da gehen die meinungen auseinander
die kollegin vom bka zählen 43 grad
bereite rechte wir kommen auf 12.700 da
sehe ich eine diskrepanz
ein junge hat er hat der kollege sich
als kind verkleidet
wieso nur so holger stockhaus meine
damen und herren
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße